alright let's talk about Facebook have
you heard of this monstrosity this giant
company that is stealing all your data
you signed up for it though so is that
stealing I'm not so sure well you know
what they're doing with your data they
are actually doing bizarre scientific
tests to depress you yeah that's right
we've got some info for one week and
early 2012 Facebook changed the content
mix in the newsfeed of about 700,000
users some were shown a higher number of
positive posts while others were shown
more negative posts the study found that
users were shown more negative content
were slightly more likely to produce
negative posts users in the positive
group responded with more upbeat posts
okay so we all talked about this all the
time the data and that we just give this
stuff away and we didn't ever read the
Terms of Service and we click YES on
everything but now they're actually
manipulating things to alter our mood
I'm pretty sure nobody signed up for
that I I hate Facebook I talk about it
constantly on this show that negative
things make people feel negatively yes
it is crazy the theory that negative
things make other negative things crazy
how do you know if you're one of the
subjects if you're already depressed all
the time like me like I don't understand
they probably would have left someone
like you out of their algorithm I mean
I'm depressed by my distant cousins
making me play candy crush saga so I
really know how much worse it could get
okay so should anyone be upset by this
really though because we sign up for
these things we know we don't read the
Terms of Service right it's a 50-page
thing that you just scroll down and
click YES on and then they're doing this
to us but it's a free service so do we
have any right even to be upset we have
a right to be upset that they showed us
things that we're depressing when we
were using their free service that we
signed up for we have a right to be
upset but do we have any recourse
against them no it's it's their baby
right so some people are trying to get
together and pull some kind of lawsuit
but I'm sure that's not gonna do any if
you go to a party voluntarily in the
SiC bums you out you're welcome to leave
yeah I mean is mr. high most sites do
these things you know when they have
like two different versions for
different users and that you see and
then does different headlines for
example to see what people click on more
you know they're all testing us yes is
just probably giving you more of your
high school friends having babies to
depress does really bummed me out but
you know it's my choice to be on
Facebook and to for whatever reason to
be friends with people I haven't seen in
12 years yeah do you guys ever find that
the positive news actually depresses you
more than the negative news you know to
me like if there is some theory on this
that if you keep seeing your friends
doing all this cool stuff like people
just by Instagram everyone's food looks
better than it actually is and you think
everyone's eating better food than you
so do you ever get more depressed by the
positive things that you see people
doing than just the people who are
suicidal well when it comes to Instagram
I'm really torn between pictures of
other people's food and pictures of
girls feet on a beach in front of bodies
of water sort of torn between those two
Polaris but uh you know I believe it was
Nietzsche who said we hate it when our
friends become successful
no that was Morrissey yeah I mean no I I
mean if it's a positive news in the
world great yeah it's positive news for
my friends if their friends that I love
it's great if their friends that I
secretly hate then you know that's my
problem in it yeah cuz I mean that's a
that's a good theory I like that I feel
like if Facebook just had more posts
hashtag blessed then I'd probably would
be more homicidal by the end of the day
are you guys with me in the general
thing like I just had it with Facebook I
just don't like anything that it's about
now I only have a fan page so I'm not
involved in in all the minutiae of
what's going on with the feed and
everything but just this connectedness
is I'm just completely over you guys no
I disagree I love it I love knowing the
names of my cousin's hideous children I
love being able to get back in touch
with the same guys who called me [ __ ]
they're coming my hair in high school
yeah you know being able to do that and
but not your later hair than that being
able to being able to get you know which
brat pack member quizzes are you ten
times a day is enriched me culture no I
mean I like Facebook I use Facebook as a
promotional tool as a comedian you know
I have a fan I have a fan page
I have I have the old profiles I used to
have and then I have a private page for
my family where I just post baby
pictures so my cousins don't think I'm a
leftist monstrosity so no I get a lot
you can have what you put into it and I
don't really get so sucked into it that
I'm giving my email information way to
apps and things like that
no Facebook apps no Facebook hacks
science' there you go so you're doing it
in the very controlled kind of way how
do you manage first of all check your
facebook fanpage privilege because not
all of us have that option I say that
with all do like gross this really no I
mean I love Facebook in the same way
that I love Twitter you know it's a
mixed bag and I feel like it's a great
promotional tool and you you use it as
you need to use it and you block people
willingly I mean I have a bunch of I
have this problem where a lot of old
women follow me on Facebook we don't
really know why but they do yell at me
and Chris has my language you talk about
the Golden Girls a lot I do we don't we
still don't really know where they came
from but I do have a facebook problem
with harassment yeah and I just make a
joke out of it because I feel like it's
a the best way to handle these my
Facebook is much better with harassment
than Twitter though because on face yes
you actually have to show your name and
identity and most people don't go to the
trouble of putting together a an alias
as they do on Twitter on Twitter these
these are these coward child men it can
come out and call you names yeah yet
they're protected by their own anonymity
that doesn't happen on Facebook I have a
policy the Twitter policy which is I
won't fight with an egg if you're just
like a Twitter egg I will not well you
want you fight with them and oh I don't
I retweet I retweet the really brilliant
stuff they're really funny stuff and
they're really mean dumb stuff yeah and
you know check their check their
follower count cuz if it's someone with
12 followers you know I used to see
Keith Oberman getting these flame wars
yeah these guys with these eggs with 12
I'm like Keith its Twitter there's girls
here what are you doing what are you
fighting like this but I honestly I I
think that it can be very instructive
and I think that you can use those
debates as a way of letting someone else
hang themselves creatively yeah alright
so final thought on this is there
anything that would get you to the point
where you'd be willing to actually get
off Facebook it like so if you know
they're doing experiments on you
there any point with which it would just
you know the straw and the camel's back
just say no I'm just gonna be really
honest about it
yeah you're said what was I'm still
promoting my stuff on Facebook like
there's it's gonna I'm gonna stay yeah
but they do anything with all this
information even if you're hiding it to
the best be the best in Union Carbide
they could be pay yeah they could be you
know funding baby seal clubbing trips I
mean there's lots of things to get done
Zuckerberg hates Eli have to he hates
everything you know lots of things that
could be done where I would want to
where I'd want to withdraw my membership
but I I think that they're smart
businessmen they create a fun service it
is a great way to keep in touch with
relatives without having to actually see
them and I think in that sense it's
gonna be around for a long time yeah all
right there you go
I hate Facebook Lewis loves Facebook and
John gave us an even keeled answer on
why may not be killing all of us
you